the Joe Rogan experience and for people
don't know your career was taken from
you in a way that you feel like didn't
medically make sense
they told you to stop fighting because
they explained the whole heart condition
thing what it was it was in the building
my boy I am part wolf yes yes I won't
tell you which part yeah I was it was in
the build at the Mike Brown fight at
Mike Brown matte Brown fight and because
it's California they're required to
bunch of different tests and it just it
showed up is an irregular heartbeat it's
like I have a second heart heartbeat so
it's another bunch of cells in the heart
that produce an electrical current and
it can confuse the heart cause cardiac
arrest it can cause you know electrical
issues with the heart I've never had any
problems never had any symptoms and side
effects or anything like that so
basically what they told me is that if I
wanted to continue fighting I had to
have an ablation so they had to go into
my heart and there to burn the the the
cells that were produced in the second
electrical shock I've never had anything
wrong with me at all healthy I've pushed
myself to whatever limits I think I've
got and I'm you know I'm hoping to find
some more but I pushed myself I know
what my heart's capable of and I just
I've never doubted it I've never felt
when we were known for having good
cardio yeah I always pushed I always
push the pace and so I I just didn't
wanna have anything done they said and
then literally said to me you can have
it done and still fight on the same day
this was five weeks before the final
John so it just haven't have its own
five weeks so how much recovery time
Oh practically none they're literally
going into the the carotid artery and
the femoral artery and they go into the
heart but Lorenzo sent me out to
California what what are they going in
there I don't know some cable goes wrong
yeah exactly
in the name of the Ironman I mean yeah
you come out with powers but Lorenzo
sent me out to Beverly Hills to a
specialist out there to have more checks
done and they couldn't find anything of
any any anomalies with my heart no like
additional growth or anything like that
so I just said I'm not having anything
done I went back to the UK and then I
was busy for a few years doing the
commentary but I did go and see a
specialist a cardiac specialist for
athletes and he put me through all the
same tests and he pointed out what
they'd
and he said that it could have been
accentuated because I was in I was wait
cut and I was in training camp I was
tired he said but ultimately there's
nothing in these records that show that
you can't fight and you're not safe to
fight so I have the paperwork now so
performance in you saw the test
important I just got my I just got the
option to step back in there I would
like one more because I never felt like
I showed what I'm fully capable of well
as I was born
oh I spoke I spy regularly I drop in the
gym because I've got I've got guys that
are training for fights so we've had
Terry brazier fighting recently Adam and
my singer Dean Truman fought recently so
I've been in there moving around with
those guys and I've never really gotten
out of training training you've always
trained martial arts yes whole time
right yeah and I've always stayed
healthy I never gained then you actually
lost weight after I stopped fighting
because you know my my diet changed I
didn't feel the need to be constantly
eating all the time so I just I allowed
my body just to kind of figure out where
it wants to be naturally 180 to 184 is
perfect for me so my plan is just to
kind of get to about 85% condition and
just sit there and then like I mean this
weekend is a great example if like you
know Pettus or Diaz fell out and there's
no one else around that's the kind of
place I'll just throw my name in the Hat
and just to be available and one of
those fights will be perfect for me just
you know one of the veterans of the
games someone that's like not too
concerned with the rankings or anything
like that drop in there have a great
fight and then step back out again and
how you'd like to approach it you want
to immediately jump back in fight
someone with a big name you fall for
sure
I wouldn't I won't want to because I'm
having one more fight I want so much one
more that's it I want someone that
everyone knows if you love it though
well I don't know I will love it but I
feel very sick I feel very selfish
thinking about fighting again anyway
because it's not what I've realized
since I've been fighting is it's not
just me coming out of retirement it's
like it's my whole family well I was I
was there I was there when till got
knocked out in London I was there when
Gunnar Nelson got knocked out in in
Glasgow I see the reactions of their
family I know what I put my family
through and because I've had time to
kind of step back and like allow them
some time to you know the the hot souls
aren't as calcified to the idea of the
fighting anymore you know so it's a
serious conversation to have but I mean
the reality is like and and you know the
sport is very different now
everything's changed like when I was
fighting GSP the conversations I was
having with the media was you know what
we are and aren't allowed to do you know
what's legal what's illegal so it wasn't
really about about why I was doing it
was about I was basically being an
ambassador for the sport while I was in
training camp so now it would it would
be far more of a an internal journey I'd
be able to to really embrace it a lot
more and focus on myself you know and
now I've got you know my camera guys I'd
like to document the process I'd like to
be able to speak quite candidly to the
camera and just bank a load of stuff so
after the fight I've got all this all
this footage that I can put into
something to kind of give some insight
into the the mentality of the fighter
and the ups and downs of training camp
because you know the days you show up to
media day to the press conference and
you're like you know you you're
confident in the stage and you [ __ ] talk
in your opponent and you smile and stuff
like you might get back to your dressing
room and you might be exhausted you
might feel like [ __ ] you might you might
have been playing the game for a
particular reason and there's a there's
a good reason you play in that game and
I think that a lot of those narratives
go untold because the sport moves so
quickly and I think I might be able to
give like a nice little insight into
that so if we are going to expect this
how much time do you think you need to
fully prepare where yeah right now I
always work on percentages I would say
physically and can I would say I'm about
about 58 percent conditioned 58 that's
interesting number yes choose that well
because I'm working circle of injuries
so I've not been doing a lot of hands-on
stuff I've been doing a lot of training
on my own I'm starting to build my
aerobic base again but the one thing
I've noticed is and like I'm I smoked
most days like my conditioning like
always is good like I can just get out
and run ten miles and feel comfortable
with it and that's never changed so all
I want I need to do is just kind of just
kind of test that that the toughness in
that condition now and push it you know
to the points where I feel uncomfortable
how old you know 37
dun-dun-duh but you know I'm healthy I'm
not you know I'm not drank in 20 years I
had a ibuprofen since 2009 you know I
just I have nothing and you have been
out of competition for how many years
now it's been seven
yeah I told you I work in cycles
yes I called you this is my this is our
seven-year cycle this is a man I hope
you do it I hope you fulfill your Vision
Quest like Matthew Modine in that movie
thanks much [ __ ] do it buddy
beautiful to see
[Applause]